let's talk about Snow White we had this
from TMZ they say Rachel zegler Snow
White old woke interview resurfaces
ignites right-wing rage it's really
weird to me that honest and
average is considered right wing because
you go and talk to the average person
and you will find they hold these
opinions so anyway you may have seen the
news they've got this image as Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs I'm pretty
sure that's not what it's called anymore
because now it's like what is it the
Seven Companions or something yeah and
one's a dwarf just the one guy just the
one so you've got you know like a white
guy you've got a couple black people you
got a fat guy another white guy a guy
who's presumably black maybe ethnically
ambiguous one uh little person and then
another guy so uh the story apparently
is the new Snow White movie will not be
about her being rescued by Prince
Charming or anything like that it's
gonna be her trying to actualize her
girl boss dreams or something yeah
we should watch the interview it's just
really that's the worst it's terrifying
two minutes here we go you said you were
bringing a Modern Edge to it on stage
what do you mean by that I just mean
that it's no longer 1937. and we
absolutely absolutely wrote a snow white
that is not going to be saved by the
prince she's not going to be safe for
The Prince and she's not going to be
dreaming about true love she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be and the leader that her late
father told her that she could be if she
was Fearless Fair Brave and true so
patreon so it's just a really incredible
story for I think young people
everywhere it's not Snow White Snow
White is running for president so you're
a Hispanic campaign
Fearless Fair Brave and true like make a
new package was it yes Snow White was
like cleaning yeah
the house yeah so but that's what she's
saying they're not gonna do Oh I thought
she was still had that same role but
then she wants to be a a boss no no no
this movie is not Snow White it's like
there's no dwarfs dwarves I don't know
worthless she never touches them but
here's what bothers me about it yo the
the the Seven Dwarves were not little
people they were fictional yes they were
creatures who mined gemstones diamonds
they needed more diversity all right
though World of Warcraft you're done you
gotta get rid of the whole dwarf race
this idea is a stereotype that little
people are mining I don't know where it
comes from but it's gone they look like
gnomes too like The Gnome the World of
Warcraft yeah they weren't like yeah
they weren't like they're fictional
mystical characters I mean this is
ridiculous like they were like they
represented emotions
now now hold on there a minute do you
think they're gonna to give these names
to these people Dopey who's gonna be
Dopey who's the one that's on heroin
yeah sleepy is also on heroin yeah yeah
grumpy just doesn't have heroin yet Doc
is just he's the pill Mill this reminds
me yeah this reminds me more of a hook
the movie with with Robin Williams and
Dustin Hoffman yes with a Peter Pan
movie and these look like the lost boys
like they're just kind of regurgitating
the Lost Boys yeah one is Rufio except
she's just drugging her all the time I'm
sorry dude this movie's gonna bounce
it's gonna bomb because here's what's
happening
regular people like I went outside I was
I'll wait touching grass actually I was
touching sand because I was in Tijuana
but I'm hanging out and talking to
regular people about all the stuff and
they're like don't know don't care this
is weird they just want regular stuff
like we're used to you can't have this
rapid
cultural shift in the span of six seven
years people are just weirded out by now
terminally online people on the woke
left will say things that make no sense
just agree with each other like uh you
know everyone brings up to me non-stop
the clip with um Lance from the Surfs
when he said a woman should be able to
get an abortion whatever she wants it's
her body and then I asked him about
Matthew as well she can't do that
intentionally kills the baby everybody
and then Dave Chappelle goes gotcha
so everybody someone made that
edit and uh that that is a contradiction
in the mind of an individual who doesn't
have convictions or logic he has tribal
acceptance he will say what he is
supposed to say and of course this is
why money leftists don't come on talk
shows because there's no logic to their
ideas they're saying things that they're
supposed to say
regular people don't live in that world
so when you bring woke snow white girl
boss and the Seven Companions they're
gonna be like oh
are they gonna do a snow white with the
prince I wanna see that also girls like
talking about love they think about it
all the time and relationships way
they're hardwired to pretend otherwise
is stupid it's disingenuous also
ridiculous I saw this interesting thing
on Twitter and it said the reason women
get offended by mansplaining is because
men and women communicate with each
other differently men talk to each other
about things they know women talk to
each other about their feelings on
average so when a man starts talking to
a woman he starts talking about
knowledge-based things and the woman
doesn't like it women talk about
feelings that's what they prefer more
and you better listen so but but
ultimately what it comes down to is
how many people really she's like it's
not 1937 anymore she's gonna be the
leader she can be okay well here's an
honest question
how many women genuinely want to be
world leaders a lot of them do don't get
me wrong I'm not saying they don't I'm
saying if I'm willing to bet if you
pulled the average woman go to Times
Square
and walk up to as many people as
possible and say would you want to rule
the world men are probably two to one
gonna say yes women two to one gonna say
no someone on Twitter it's I'm not
saying it's absolute a lot of women will
say yes for sure no but a lot of these
stories have to come from a place of
knowing and I guarantee you a man wrote
the script or green litter gave notes
like there's an SNL sketch not that they
ever do very well with it but there's
one where it's like a house full of
people and it's like one of the reality
shows and there's lesbians and the whole
joke is the two women are laying in bed
together and they're going like I see
you I know I see you too I see you and I
see you and it's hilarious because if a
guy wrote that it would be like what Doc
Martens they both were construction like
it would be this hacky but it was
actually really funny because it was
written from a place of understanding
who they actually were to make fun of it
so you have this thing that doesn't
actually make sense to any guy and you
probably have these Studio heads going
like yeah she wants to be a boss lady
like we'll do it like that right that's
what all women want and you're not going
to get anything that connects with an
audience so here's the issue how many uh
how many women want to see a movie about
a woman being in charge and how many men
want to see a movie where they're like
the man is not needed and not useful
none
I'm sure some right some market for it
but it's probably small well yeah here's
the question why are there so many how
come none how come 95 of strip clubs are
women
the girls at work there you mean the
people that work there yeah 95 of strip
clubs are women stripping I would say
testosterone is probably the number one
reason how come it's not 50 50. yeah
these feminists males want to go there
it's it's interesting it's like they're
not seeking out the women you know what
you know why fantasizing about
impregnating women bear movies and those
fat ants sure go to town women on
average are not attracted to submissive
men who are being controlled by someone
else
I was reading studies on the disparity
and what they've found is women go to
male strip clubs typically because it's
funny
women women go to female strip clubs
because it's funny man go to female
strip clubs because they're horny
what they said was that women are not
attracted to weak men who are being
dominated by somebody else going into a
big room where the man has to perform
for a group of people who are hooting
and hollering is not typically
attractive to a woman
oh
it's seeing the creep that can come out
in men who get way to arouse at a strip
club I would imagine it's not it's like
the girl from The Office who's like I'll
go I don't mind seeing that but then
she'll never talk to you again right
because she's seen you at your lowest
point
like if you go like if you go to a strip
club a male strip club have you been no
I've never been done but I like so I was
on I've never been to Danny's in Windsor
no I can't say like but the thing is I
have noticed a bunch of names
among my people go to cheetahs and the
girls would go over there and giggle
yeah like and we would be at what is
especially a whorehouse I've known girls
who do that and they're like haha look
how empowered so fun but like what's up
going there for any reason right they're
going there to be like I'm so forward
thinking and edgy right it's the same
thing with like when you have like
bachelorette parties and they go to drag
shows right like at bars hopefully
appropriately age but like they're going
because it's like kind of something fun
and different men go to strip clubs for
an entirely different reason they don't
go just to be like look at this fun
group activity we're doing like I'm
sorry you guys are creepy and weird guys
go by themselves yeah I've never met a
girl who's like going alone to a
all-male strip club or like any of this
it's ridiculous you do she's broken in
every way I mean I don't watch it I feel
bad for her I think part of it is is
important to acknowledge that like men
and women
seek different things out of emotional
relationships and even like watching
movies right so so there are reasons
what you'll you'll have this stereotype
of like the movie you go with your
boyfriend to see versus the movie your
girlfriend takes you to see uh I think
the example of this weekend of Barbie
and Oppenheimer right people are talking
about this like in a gendered way uh
what I think is dumb about this this
she's not even thinking about falling in
love like that's just such a lie why are
you stripping women from their emotional
core like women are hardwired to seek
community and relationships and part of
that is finding a life partner and
that's cool and beautiful and if you
want her to be you know CEO of not dwarf
Industries or whatever that's fine but
to be like because she's too good to be
thinking about love that's sort of ugly
towards women right that's saying that
these things that you feel naturally are
thinking something you should be ashamed
of and avoid and that's a weird movie
for a message to send I I do like a
message for a movie to send I do like
that Gal Gadot is the evil queen
because like Gal Gadot looks at Rachel
zegler and she's like I am jealous of
how beautiful she is like you look the
same kind of ugly woman to play that
role for well I think the evil queen was
beautiful but she still was jealous that
was part of her yeah Maleficent or
whatever is that who it was yeah Melissa
it's not that Millicent isn't beautiful
it's just that she's jealous and part of
like Snow White's beauty is like the
fact that she's so kind and and she's
sweet and things like that there's
there's a youthfulness about her that
you know this woman is jealous of and
that is actually a super interesting
concept women should explore that
because jealousy is rampant among women
right no you know what women really did
like though that movie where the uh the
dude kidnaps the woman's dad and then
she gets Stockholm syndrome and marries
him uh Beauty and the Beast ah yeah they
do like that movie and he's not even a
good looking fella what happens see
women are not as visually oriented as
men who kidnaps who in that movie uh the
dad yeah yeah yeah the Beast kidnapped
her kidnaps her dad y'all made a billion
dollars yeah made a billion dollars
beauty is that the live-action one where
it's like the Beast doesn't even look
that good fortunately and it's it's
literally a movie about a monster that
kid that like blackmails and extorts
them and saying either live with me or
I'm gonna kidnap your dad and then she
falls in love with him and he has a big
Library she's a big Library like he's
got assets that she's interested in and
you know she's not interested I remember
watching The Animated Beauty and the
Beast movie and I've talked to other
girls about this and when they finally
show the prince after he like stops
being the Beast like you're actually
like well he's kind of disappointing the
Beast was like much more like
interesting looking there there is
something that women are not compelled
by the way that men are I think that's
the weirdest thing that Hollywood is
trying to sometimes argue that like
ultimately women are just as visually
oriented as men that they were looking
for the same things men they're not
that's why they're different there's a
reason for this so that's okay
somebody's a big bear man who talks to
Spoons yeah like dude he's got a castle
and he dresses nicely and he got some
books that's what they're saying on X
someone was asking earlier that
um
uh yeah they xed out that um yeah that's
the best one women want a strong male
protective force in their life thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time